Boeing 737 української авіакомпанії Sky
Up виконував рейс ташкенту до Києва саме
у ці хвилини коли Росія почала своє
вторгнення в Україну на підльоті до
України надгрузією літак раптово
переспрямували в Молдову капітаном
догорейсу був Сергій Булат уже тоді в
небі Пілот розумів вдома щось
відбувається
на Бориспіль коли отримали команду про
посадку в аеропорту Кишинів
і вже після посадки в принципі Ми
отримали доступ до інтернету і узнали
масштаби того що сталося
авіакомпанія вирішила залиши
лися 6 березня ми виконали перший
евакуаційний рейс із Кишинева на
тель-авів далі звідти гуманітарний
вантаж назад на кишеню після цього
почали літати Ну майже кожен день
пригадує Пілот тоді для евакуації не
вистачало екіпажу пізніше до нього
доєднався колега капітан Геннадій
Фоменко разом вони зробили близько 25-ти
рейсів це залежало більше від того як
наскільки інтенсивно під'їжджали біженці
там був табір для біженців і ми як
тільки на них були готові документи
набирався повний літак ми виконували
рейси Ну щоб було багато інвалідів на
цих рейсах Ну в принципі по 30-40
інвалідів було таке Що там по 40 тварин
на борту також всі вивозили собак кішок
і так далі разом з колегами
залишалися в Україні Мариною Родина в
цей момент знаходилась у Борисполі
дружина військовослужбовець донька жила
у військовій частині разом з нею
[музика]
Тобто було доволі важко
проте Ані емоційне напруження Ані
виснажливий графік згадує Пілот тоді не
мали значення адже кожен політ рейс
врятованого життя
[музика]
доволі Важко було глину що що тут якби
що сказати
Я розумію на той момент що все що я можу
робити
для для нас для всіх це було те що
робити свою роботу просто
[музика]
прийшла до того щоб втілити свою мрію
стати бортпровідницею Утім за
спеціальністю вона встигла попрацювати
лише два місяці
24-го почалася війна а 25 в мене повинен
був бути рейс вже ж було все
підготовлено форма була погладжена все
було і тут нам пишуть що небо закрито
все
до роботи в небі Владислава повернулася
лише у травні перші два рейси були
евакуаційні теж до Ізраїлю це були і
мами і дітки і люди похилого віку і
тварини знаєте це були і собаки і коти і
хом'яки якісь були в нас навіть так
відчуття було те що ми їх не веземо до
тель-авіву ми веземо їх до Києва в
Бориспіль тому що в нас таке знаєте
відчуття було ось українського духу всі
ось ці еволюційні та гуманітарні риси
вони були з рідною душею українські такі
пасажири співали пісні атмосфера була
неймовірна пригадує Владислава
емоційно Важко було але ми трималися
тому що в першу чергу в нас на першому
плані Це була робота щоб все було добре
знаєте що все було за нашими стандартами
так як нас навчали так як в нас повинно
бути звісно ми підходили до кожного
Питали як у вас справи Як Ви давайте
порозмовляємо та найбільше владиславі
запам'ятався грудневий рейс у Стокгольм
тоді на борту летіло 100 медиків 40 з
них тільки-но з лінії фронту ось тоді
емоції знаєте так нахлинули хотілося
плакати але ми не подавали виду і ми її
показували всім серцем всієї душею що
все буде гаразд Дякуємо вам за те що ви
робите коли я
вітала медиків так наших військових
я знаєте руки так за спинку так Доброго
дня вітаємо але я відчувала що в мене
такі знаєте мурахи тому що хлопці коли
заходили Вони хотіли обійтися а ми ще не
можемо так знаєте буде черга і ми такі
ми з вами підійдемо ми об’ємось і потім
коли ми вже прилетіли до Стокгольму то
ми напевно з кожним обмінялися
Саме цей політ назавжди залишив слід у
серці борд провідниці самотіло воно
показувало що люди з лінії фронту
це знаєте
навіть важко сказати тому що є такий
процес старіння Так але ти дивишся на
людину і ти навіть не можеш сказати
скільки людині років
зараз Владислава як волонтерка допомагає
українським дітям з вивченням польської
мови дає онлайн уроки проте найбільше
чекає нових рейсів дуже хочеться Вже
літати
в Україні і напевно перший рейс Я дуже
хочу полетіти з Києва до Харкова
про польоти українським небом мріє Пілот
Сергій Булат звичайно особливо важко
коли прилітаєш поруч з Україною ти її
бачиш
завернути туди неможливо